I have another great example for you
from Fox News in trying to keep the
property the propaganda narrative set by
Donald Trump going Fox News brought on a
doctor to talk about chloroquine
unfortunately they brought on the wrong
doctor I think you're really going to
like this this is an interview with dr.
William Haseltine William Haseltine was
interviewed by Fox host Dana Perino Dana
Perino you might remember was george w
bush's press secretary at one point
Haseltine is a well-known biologist
entrepreneur philanthropist he's a 75
year old guy now did very important work
on hiv/aids did important work on the
human genome taught at Harvard Medical
School this is a serious guy he's
serious in the medical world he's
serious in the business world and he
does not take Dana Perino's BS when she
now tries to keep pushing chloroquine as
a possible coronavirus treatment which
is exactly what Donald Trump has been
doing let's get to dr. Haseltine
starting to shut down Dana Perino sir
can you tell me your thoughts about this
draw everybody wants to find a cure or a
treatment or a therapy for coronavirus
what do you think about the drug that is
used normally to treat malaria well
thank you for the question and it's sad
to me that people are promoting that
drug we know already from studies at
best it will have a very mild effect at
very best there are studies that
conflict a little bit one from the other
one concludes it has no effect yeah they
can close it has a mild effect the net
result is whatever effect it has it will
be very mild that drug has been used for
years against many other viruses to no
effect they think that makes me sad
about that story because some people may
take it who are on other medications who
are other underlying conditions
they have very serious even
life-threatening consequences it is not
something to take unless a doctor
prescribes it so notice that in 45
seconds he refutes just about everything
that Donald Trump has been saying Trump
says what do you have to lose
doctor Haseltine explains you can lose
your life it has life-threatening side
effects for some people Trump says it's
working really well
dr. Haseltine explains there are
conflicting reports but it is either
mild or no impact and here Dana Perino
continues pushing because this is not
going well to push Trump's narrative and
now dr. Haseltine straight-up calls some
of the claims nonsense and says it is
reminiscent of quack cures when people
continue to push this and what about the
I know you don't go by anecdotal
evidence but there are stories of people
saying that they don't have this Lazarus
effect by using this drug that is
nonsense
complete and utter nonsense and in any
situation there are always going to be
people who promote one kind of quack
cure or another and there are Lazarus
effects in every epidemic I've ever
looked at it's always the case let me
just repeat we know that at very best
this drug will have a very mild effect
on changing the course of the disease if
it has any effect at all that is what
the data has shown so far and I am
convinced that that's what further
studies will show and it's not without
adverse consequence it is irresponsible
to promote this drug at this time in
absolutely the most direct terms so far
a doctor on Fox News saying promoting
this like an exciting new product is
irresponsible and Dana Perino simply
unable to say much else because she's
not a doctor in the end and she could
only reference this vague anecdotal
evidence and that's another Fox News
segment gone wrong once again so you
have to understand Fox News has invested
in the Trump narrative when Trump was
downplaying coronavirus
box was downplaying coronavirus when
Trump started using the word hoax in a
coy way related to coronavirus Fox News
started using the word hoax fox has been
one of the biggest promoters of
chloroquine allowing 109 claims during a
three-day period in March about how well
the drug functions with only 15 claims
during that same three-day period which
cast any doubt on the efficacy of
chloroquine to treat coronavirus they
even bring on TV doctors people very
different than doctor Haseltine
including dr. oz to promote chloroquine
and so when we see a real doctor who is
a serious person smack down a Fox News
host it is very entertaining but the
most important thing is we don't go any
farther one way or the other than what
the science says dr. Haseltine may be
right it may have a small effect there
are dozens of things being tested we
should go through the process with
everything and not pick one drug to
promote like a miracle cure which is
what Donald Trump has been doing if it
turns out chloroquine with or without
azithromycin works well for certain
patient profiles for example or at
certain stages of the disease that's
great
remember I've been talking about
chloroquine and as a throme Ison much
longer than Donald Trump has but we've
got to follow the science we can't turn
this into a propaganda fest we don't
pick a medication like a sports team and
promote it no matter what the facts are
good for dr. Haseltine for setting dr.
Perino straight i can't imagine he will
be invited back on the program we
continue to cover the trials of various
medications on the david pakman show
instagram page at david pakman show make
sure you're following we'll be back
right after this our sponsor Nord VPN is
giving you 70% off a three year plan
which is just a little over three bucks
a month and you will get an extra month
three when you go to Nordby pn comm
slash david pakman or just go to their
website and use the coupon code david
pakman
by this point in time if you're not
using a VPN when you're on the Internet
you are putting yourself at a huge
disadvantage Nord VPN keeps your IP
address hidden when you're browsing
online keeps your personal data safe
from hackers prevents web sites from
following you around the internet and
you can even use it on your phone there
are many different VPN options out there
but Nord VPN is the one I trust because
they don't log your internet history
they use military-grade encryption and
they encrypt your data twice to double
the anonymity Nord VPN is giving you 70%
off a 3-year plan that's just over three
bucks a month plus an extra month free
when you go to North Vee PN comm slash
David Pakman I've put a link right
underneath the video or just go to their
website and use the coupon code david
pakman